well actually 40 degree around I really
like how it like basically everything
within the class yeah guys go ahead you
do everyday I was very personal I also
like thought like well he said that it
covered everything in the class which I
think it's also important giving that
we're sharing this class to the world so
I like to cover everything you say yeah
yeah and we're gonna talk a little more
about like technology and specifically I
mean I think it was like more
appropriate I also like the fact that
you like reference readings from weeks I
thought it was
the first draft I was very worried they
let me do that lots of work between then
and today so I'm very very pleased the
connection a certain and as was said
before it was a nice way to because you
know the perfect less impatient because
you did manage to bring lots of threads
together and you did reference the
readings and andyecosse
I wish I did a bit more about the
technology parts but you know ten
minutes I think even beyond ten minutes
yeah you as much do so which means that
maybe I assigned too many meetings for
that for that one time so yes it was
well done and also the personal thoughts
were well chosen and appropriate and
brought extra light on the discussion
and and great questions great questions
definitely in fact one could keep
thinking about these you know fourth
yeah for example for a long time we had
in fact they it's a nice way to go into
the world after this class because I
think they're going to keep coming back
in in your interaction and I'm going to
send you some references on this issue
of growth mindset versus fixed mindset
so actually in black matters we had last
week we had them actually someone from
digital running a fella man who goes
with me to Haiti she did do two
workshops with the students about growth
mindset with his fixed mindset
and she and she yeah and she had some
very interesting references which I will
share with you because I think we
connect very interesting to
instructional of identity who makes it
for you and how can you go beyond what
was imposed on you for your own self in
terms of seeing as an asset versus a
liability so well done
you
[Applause]